what are the top three keys to being
happy people people I do not people I'm
looking for tips on how to be more happy
do you have any advice if I do something
like cool it makes me feel like happy um
I think being with people you love will
drink their happiness so much because
you're always just chill when I hang out
with my family when cats appears out of
the darkness when they just appear I
wouldn't say like that but okay what can
I do to be happier what stuff you love
to do I love dancing I love going out to
eat I love finessing billionaires every
two minutes you go outside and you say
guys I need my two minutes every day and
you're gonna go you're gonna turn your
favorite Jam on and you're gonna dance
I'm gonna dance I can't really help you
with finessing billionaires you know
what I'm still working on that you know
I'll get there what does happiness mean
it means feeling having a good day and
and feeling good about yourself yeah
that's a good answer I just feel like I
could just slide over a rainbow what are
your top three keys to happiness cats
chocolate and candy oh my god for my
friends and my family I like where your
friends and family come on that way
what's something you do when you want to
make yourself happy yeah that's that's a
good thing not to do it okay to do bad
things
depends what kinda Matt thanks okay if
you're robbing people's houses and
that's what makes you happy you need to
stop do you ever have a sad day I
usually have happy days that must be so
nice well if you just joined a beautiful
day you'll have a good time you have any
tips for making my mornings happier so I
get out of bed if you have an alarm
clock don't make it like that annoying
ringing make it a pleasant sounds that
makes you really want to get out if you
love dancing put dance music so it makes
you feel energizing you just dance oh my
god like a trap music alarm clock
yeah that sounds amazing have you ever
heard of depression yeah it's a very
deep sadness it's when something's
happened that you can't recover from and
you get this place where it's so hard to
come back up I've dealt with depression
too there have been times where I went
to school every dangerous got mold and
believe it it sucked so bad but I found
the people I love and the things I love
to support me you got through and I got
through so tell all the people were
watching this you get through it
my sister hasn't been talking to me
lately how do I get her to talk to me
what can I do
oh so if I say it louder
that'll get through to her so sometimes
do you know what Instagram is okay I go
on my phone and I can look at pictures
of what all my friends are doing so
they're on like vacation doing these
amazing things with their career and
they seem really happy and then
sometimes that makes me sad like I
should be doing more do you know any way
that I could not feel that way maybe if
you does not look at them genius you
know what I'm gonna delete my Instagram
right now I'm just kidding I can't do
that what makes you happy so I would say
my family and then my friends and I
really really liked going to the beach
me too that's a happy place let's be
honest this is good choice what makes
you happy I like to collect like old
books so I like to go to the library
sometimes and I like to read like really
old dusty romance but
because of many reasons but look what
makes me happy what would you do if
there was something you could do to make
every person in the world happy what do
you think that would be loving people
yeah
loving everybody yeah that's a good
answer what do you like to do with your
friends I like to usually play around
with them like play like dress-up well
we don't really usually play dress-up
mmm been a long time same even if you're
feeling really really sad
just smile work on your smiling and that
will always make you feel better even if
you're the saddest of saddest of SADS
I like that can give me a smile if you
just don't think about the badness still
does have goodness that's really
insightful so any last advice to me mr.
Joffe
you are definitely a joyful person your
parents gave you joys for a reason so
you should live like your name
you should be Joyce - joyful thank you
so much Tobi
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part